Lucky you. You get to do another challenge
problem right now. Here we have two
polynomials once again. This one has 4
terms and this one has 3 terms and I
would like you to multiply them together,
and of course, simplify as much as
possible. I know that you're probably not
very pleased with me for asking you to do
this, but the reason I am asking you to do
it is because I think that this is a
great way to make sure that you're
actually being very careful with writing
out every step in the process for solving
this problem. So I know it's not going to
be particularly exciting, but if you're
careful the first time you do it, then you
won't have to do it again. So I'll just
remind you. Write everything out, and
remember you just want to take each term
in the first set of parentheses and
multiply it by every term in the second
set of parentheses. And then, add all
those many, many terms together and
simplify. Good luck.